for many Americans eating healthier
would be a top New Year's resolution and
one expert says we should start by
eliminating gluten dr. David Perlmutter
claims eating foods high in
carbohydrates causes brain inflammation
and can trigger neurological disorders
like anxiety depression and ADHD
Perlmutter revised and updated his
best-selling 2013 book grain brain the
surprising truth about wheat carbs and
sugars your brain silent killers but in
a statement to CBS this morning the
sugar Association says this it believes
that sugar is best enjoyed in moderation
and decades of research support this
fact dr. David Perlmutter
good morning join us to the table I have
to say I'm on the side of the sugar
people because when I was reading your
book I have to tell you this I was
reading your book that night for dinner
I'd had truffle pasta cos truffles are
in season and I had a raspberry filled
donut for dessert and I'm doing all the
things wrong that you say not to that's
an anomaly I don't normally eat that
badly but but I was doing all the things
that you say don't do because you're
saying we shouldn't eat grain at all if
we want to have a healthy brain actually
let me first comment on the sugar issue
I mean we we should definitely believe
the sugar industry like we should have
believed the tobacco industry years ago
when they told us that smoking
cigarettes were good for our health but
you know to have some grain if it's
gluten-free is not going to be the end
of the world it's the total carbs that
we're really interested in it was
interesting how the last segment on junk
food affecting your sleep that's
directly threatening to brain function
the next day and long-term and you know
I think it's really important to
understand that the choices we make
today while we're younger are going to
have an effect on the brain as we get
older and once that happens there's
actually very little we can do so
prevention is the mantra of the day well
you say you've heard of a cancer
survivor you've never heard of an
Alzheimer's survivor and it starts
really in our 20s and 30s that's right
that we should you know how incredible
it is that the Journal of the American
Medical Association just last month
published a review of the so called
Alzheimers medications and indicated
that not only do they not work but they
actually are associated with more rapid
cognitive decline so we really have to
emphasize prevention and we have that
understanding now you're suggesting that
grain causes Alzheimer's I'm suggesting
that sugar and high carbohydrates is
absolutely related to Alessandra and not
just that dr. Perlmutter on your program
is suggesting that but that's what our
most well respected peer-reviewed
journals are telling us and that's the
inconvenient truth that we need to
really talk about
so the Alzheimer's Association said who
doesn't have the same kind of
relationship I don't think that the one
you were suggesting with the sugar folks
says this about you promoter sites
preliminary research and Dietary
Guidelines that may have value for some
health conditions but cannot be applied
with any certainty to Alzheimer's or
other dementia
well you know when you're getting a
statement from an organization that is
supported by makers of so-called
Alzheimer's drugs that sort of mentality
is not surprising the bottom line is we
know Alzheimer's is to a great extent
and preventable disease and a disease
for which we have no treatment so my
mission and it has been for decades to
really get that information out to you
and the rest of the world that our
lifestyle choices are fundamentally
important in terms of determining your
brains destiny so you know the idea of
waiting for a magic pill there's nothing
on the horizon so but don't you agree
that the Alzheimer's Association would
want to do everything possible to
eradicate the disease I think that they
would and I I would agree with you and I
think that the understanding that
lifestyle choices are really very very
important is something that they've not
fully embraced as yet that's my mission
so what is the lifestyle choice that
somebody needs to make immediately to
avoid the biggest issue sugar and how
incredible that we led this segment with
talking about sugar that is according to
the New England Journal of Medicine
something that powerfully relates to
increased risk for Alzheimer's disease I
want to be ruled a tiger over there
simple sugars anything that's going to
raise your blood sugar as they published
way back in that I put in the first
edition of grain brain in 2012 that
there's a perfect correlation between
even subtle elevations of your blood
sugar well below the range of diabetes
and a future risks of exciting analysis
you talk about the connection between
diabetes and Alzheimer's
I thought was interesting yes the if you
become a type-2 diabetic you may have
quadrupled your risk for this disease
that I say has no treatment so probably
have a heart attack though before you
get Alzheimer's well I mean I don't know
if that's good news or bad news but why
increase your risk for either of those
what do you want to do your best to
reduce risk that's what people ask you
to respond to dr. David Katz who is at
Yale University prevention research is
well regarded yes scientists their
energy said I also find it sad that your
book is filled with a whole bunch of
nonsense that it's misleading people
suggesting that there is a magic cure
for something as complex as the book
doesn't even address the cure for
Alzheimer's that's the his where he got
sidetracked I have a lot of respect for
him people with all due respect tend to
be down on what their not up on and the
book has everything to do with
prevention so I you know if somebody's
is about treatment of Alzheimer's that's
not what grain brain is about so quickly
three simple steps you can make to get
the sugar out of your diet increase your
dietary fat who knew
fat is your friend good exercise will
get there but eat things like olive oil
nuts and seeds fat was taken off the
table as we know for the wrong reasons
thirty years ago reality is your brain
needs fat your brain is 70 not just your
brain I'm not picking on eggs avocado
eggs eggs remember the dreaded egg I
shouldn't eat eggs is a third thing
aerobic exercise you don't have to have
cardi B on your team you can we gotta go
but exercise is key that's bet it's
right the revised and updated grain
brain is out today